now new nhs figures show that accident
and emergency departments had one of
their worst months in july and the
average waiting time for ambulances for
the most serious incidents is the joint
worst it has ever been longer than
before the pandemic
in terms of those numbers the target for
ambulances uh is to arrive for the most
serious emergencies uh in seven minutes
in july that number the average waiting
time for life-threatening ambulance
instance was nine minutes and 35 seconds
that's up 30 seconds since june and more
than two minutes longer than before the
pandemic
the target waiting time for category 2
incidents like heart attacks or strokes
is 18 minutes the average waiting time
for those in july was 59 minutes and 7
seconds the second worst since records
began and that's more than 30 minutes
longer than levels from before the
pandemic sky's adele robinson has spent
the day university hospital coventry
where she's been speaking to patients
and staff
another heat wave but the nhs is in the
depths of what's likened to a winter
crisis ambulance call outs at record
levels response time delays too putting
lives at risk patients are coming to
harm every day because of holds on the
lack of ambulances
there's the patients that you can see
there's the patients in the department
there's some patients on the back of the
ambulance who can't get in but we're
still they the unquantified patients in
the community of the ambulance can't get
out to
there may be dozens of outstanding calls
and that could be
you know your mum later laid on the
floor with a broken leg that the
ambulance group can't get out to because
they're stuck outside of our hospital
hello
amid bleak statistics a glimmer of light
for the nhs progress cutting 18-month
weights for treatment cancer targets
however are still not being met robert's
grateful he's been treated on time i
think
you don't want any more than a couple of
weeks
as if some people have to wait a long
time it must be that must be awful for
them
especially if they've got
cancer that
needs to be treated people waiting on
trolleys in a e for a hospital bed for
more than 12 hours were also at their
highest levels ever in july
it's not just one issue it's multiple
covered patients staff absences
vacancies and the heat waves aren't
helping but the main issue is the number
of people who are ready to leave
hospital but have nowhere to go
an average of 13 000 patients a day in
july were stuck ready to be discharged
the challenge for hospitals is often
we're kind of in the middle of it where
we have pressure from both
the front door and then the back door
for cartoons so we've become
we have a number of places for example
in my hospital today we have nearly 200
patients who don't actually need to be
here if we start to unravel some of that
flow working closely with community and
social care then that helps the whole
system out not just us
there are plans in place to try to ease
pressures in the coming months but the
worry is the writing's already on the
wall regarding another perhaps deeper
winter crisis adele robinson sky news
coventry